je ne le veux pas
Salut, lis quand même le nom Toto
Bonjour, Baba, je suis Farid, et je l'ai embrassé un peu
Suzanne ono wae la taille de la peine de mort sont
ma valentine a fait du sport depuis
de toute façon Saidi je suis cakula masamo incroyable
Da'wah bien jengjeng nurfa cambanh nous
C'est bon, grand-mère, je n'aime pas les baznas de couleur
balakama wasonda nah Même si je ne veux pas
il y a ta jeunesse yarojaku medial ecoute indogo
Utiliser le riz de Mami, j'ai aussi konark
L'appel de Cemara à courir plus tard, mami
Cheikh
Prêtre de la ferme Gajeel la couleur de Nope
il est manasin inné j'aime ma
ami dans
[Musique]
[Taper]
salut salut
[Musique]
le salon